how did you first find out that there
were deep fakes of you
my husband actually told me um
because he uh is friends with ashton
kutcher and so he
actually told him like oh by the way
there are these things called deep fakes
and
your wife is one of them deep fakes use
machine learning to fabricate events
that never happened
like bill hader shape-shifting i said
seth rogen was like you know
it was amazing he has like a you know a
bike track in his backyard it was
phenomenal
and and i did a seth rogen impression
and it was like i did a magic trick tom
cruise was like
[Laughter]
[Applause]
and there's growing concern that in the
wrong hands this technology can pose a
real national security threat could
impact the 2020 election
could become a real and present danger
to our democracy dana
but the most pressing daily threat of
deep fakes isn't politics
it's porn people are hijacking women's
faces to make porn videos they
never consented to be in which is why
this kind of defect is harmful
even when people know it's not real
i um was just shocked
because this is my face belongs to me
in a september 2019 survey researchers
at deep trace found that of the deep
fake videos they could identify online
96 were pornographic and that
more or less 100 of these videos are of
women
and are non-consensual pornhub and other
big porn streaming sites have policies
banning deep fakes
though they don't seem to be enforcing
them mostly these videos show up on
separate sites
dedicated to this kind of abuse it's not
just celebrities anymore not that
celebrities feel any less pain from
from these videos but the phenomenon is
evolving
at a rate where we are seeing dpa
pornography increasing
in number and an increasing number of
victims as well
i was at work and i
got an email on my phone
in fact i can even bring up the email
25th of may
4 18 pm fyi
there is a deep fake video of you on
some porn sites
it looks real i remember sitting down
receiving that email and i think it was
like you're frozen for that moment of
time
it was depicting me having sexual
intercourse
and the title of the video had my full
name
and then i saw another video that was
depicting me
performing oral sex noelle is an
australian law graduate she's not a
celebrity
someone took photos she shared on social
media and first photoshopped them into
nude images
then graduated to deep fake videos
what's happening in these videos is a
specific kind of digital manipulation
and it's unlike older face swapping
filters you might have used
those tools let you put your face into
your friend's head but you still
controlled it
a sort of video photoshop transferring
both your facial features
and your expressions but deep fix can
take the facial features
alone and animate that face with the
expressions of someone else
[Applause]
this is what makes the fake porn videos
so invasive the creator takes away a
victim's control of her own face
and uses it for something she never
wanted transferring just the mask of
someone's facial features requires
training a piece of software
called an auto encoder on hundreds of
images of the same face
from different angles and in different
lighting with different expressions
until it learns what they all have in
common that volume of images has long
been available of celebrities
but increasingly it exists of anyone
if you're someone not even with a very
intense social media presence but just a
presence online you have a few pictures
maybe there's a video of you
from you know a party or something like
this you have so many
training images to take from that at the
moment you do still need
a fair bit of data to make a convincing
deep fake but
as the technology is improving we're
needing less data and
the tools are becoming increasingly
accessible and user-friendly and there's
a growing infrastructure for deep fix
it's not just about posting the videos
it's also about forums discussing
how to make them how to target certain
individuals
in fact the term deep fake originated as
the name of a subreddit for swapping
celebrity faces onto porn stars
reddit banned the page but the
conversation just moved to other sites
so you have almost directories about
okay you want to make a deep fake of a
certain celebrity
here are adult performers that will best
suit that
there is a lot of money to be made from
selling custom deep fakes
users pay for deep fakes of specific
celebrities or
even women they know personally
and they discuss whether all of this is
legal some think they can protect
themselves by identifying the videos as
fake
but that's not true if you live in the
u.s and someone makes porn with your
face
you can sue the creator whether or not
they've marked it as a deep fake
what is true is it's very difficult to
actually do that
you'd need to pay to bring a lawsuit
with no certainty you'd be able to
secure a punishment
or even find the creator let alone stop
the video from spreading
some people on these sites question the
morality of what they're doing
and disagree about how they'd feel if it
happened to them but it probably won't
happen to them
that's the point taking a woman's face
and putting it into this context
is part of a long history of using
sexual humiliation against women
you know we're having this gigantic
conversation about consent
and i don't consent so that's why it's
not okay
even if it's labeled as this is not
actually her
it's hard to think about that this is
kind of
the probably one of the most difficult
things because
fake porn and my name
will be forever associated my children
my future children will have to see
things
my future partner will have to see
things and that's what makes me sad
yeah i just i i wish that the internet
were a little bit more responsible
and a little bit kinder